la policía Metropolitana de Londres
scotland ha iniciado una investigación
para esclarecer si este hecho está
relacionado con un accidente de tránsito
o por el contrario está asociado con
terrorismo lo que se sabe hasta el
momento es que sobre las 4 y 20 de la
tarde hora local un carro gris estrechó
se estrelló contra la puerta principal
de la calle down Street que es donde
está la residencia privada y la oficina
del Primer Ministro Richie sunak y
también del ministro de finanzas Jeremy
Hunt la policía que custodia downing
Street fuertemente Armada capturó
rápidamente a un hombre cuya identidad
no se conoce pero fue arrestado por
sospecha de daños criminales y
conducción peligrosa como lo recordabas
no hay heridos lo ha mencionado la
policía en este momento el sector White
Hall que es donde están las oficinas del
gobierno la burocracia
del gobierno está fuertemente custodiada
por la policía incluso hay presencia de
helicópteros Este es un punto bien
turístico de Londres la referencia es el
parlamento británico el big ben Así que
estamos a la espera de que la policía
entregue un nuevo reporte sobre este
hecho